look what he said he
said
said whoever from the Believers is in a
land where they are weak or a time when
they are weak then let them act upon the
verses encouraging with patience and to
ignore and disregard those who insult
Allah and his messenger from the people
of the book and the polytheists however
as for those who possess strength
meaning when you have a Muslim ruler a
Muslim government Muslim countries then
they act upon the verses that
encouraging with fighting the heads of
disbelief who protect the religion
meaning this is for the ruler and the
state a clear difference yes the state
can defend itself and its
interests now brothers and sisters these
are emotional times without a shadow of
a doubt for us all but we must make sure
that our feelings and emotions are
anchored by the Quran and the sun of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam as
blind emotions can lead to destruction
one of the companions W he gave us this
Inari one of the companions
he advised us about watching being
cautious about emotions and how emotions
can lead to
destruction he
said he said always beware and suspect
opinions meaning Bas based upon
emotions beware of opinions that are
based upon emotions and he gave the
reason why he
said
he said because I saw myself on the day
of Abu jandal what day was that can
anyone tell
me he said I saw myself on the day of
Abu jandel if I had the power to refuse
the order of the messenger of Allah I
would I would have refused it and Allah
and his messenger always know what is
best what was the day of Abu
jandel hudia the companion said out they
thought that they were going to the Kaa
but the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he made an agreement a treaty a
PCT with the pus of Mecca and
also it was mentioned in that pact one
they wasn't going to be able to go at
that particular time to go to the Kaa
that's one thing and also the Muslims
that were fleeing from persecution in
Mecca and going to Medina they would
have to be handed back and one of them
was going to be handed back right there
on that
occasion because the polytheist said
okay let's see the treaty
now you know give give him to us so it
was a test so obviously emotions were
high look what he said always be careful
about opinions meaning based on emotions
when you're emotional be careful don't
type on Instagram don't make a video be
careful especially in this day and age
you may type something a tweet and later
on you go for a a job or whatever you're
going to travel and they pull it up
because it was an it was an error and it
oppos the Quran and the Sunnah and now
you're you have problems now we're not
worried about speaking the H with wisdom
we're not worried about speaking the
truth with wisdom you know we don't fear
the blame of the blamers you know they
already harass Us in he Subhan Allah
British Citizen and still you're
harassed in he they should be harassing
the terrorist that they need to
harass so it's expected they got nothing
better to do and believe it Muslims
islamophobia is ramped all around the
world anyone who tells you otherwise is
lying they systematic the systematic
targeting of Muslims all over the world
I don't care who says any different some
places better than others like I said me
I've witnessed it even in he up until
today still harassed can't use the
electronic Gates have to go you know and
listen to a foolish bunch of questions
wasting people's time nothing about
anything that is even remotely relatable
and then they say you know go upon your
business if I'm a threat stop me take me
to the police
station but
again Prejudice and being second class
citizens that's something that Muslims
should expect and at the end of the day
alhamd we'll be patient with it because
again oppression will haunt the
individuals that do it those individuals
that Target individuals who are innocent
and they want to abuse their Authority
they're going don't worry Allah will
deal with them either now or later don't
worry about it and when you when you
have the mentality aldah it doesn't
plague you it doesn't bother you because
you go about your business alhamdulillah
again the principle we act upon we obey
Allah concerning you even if you disobey
Allah concerning
us so as for those people that are
saying you know the people of Sunnah are
agents you seem to be traveling easily
you know we're the ones being harassed
these guys are the ones calling aah
agents you guys seem to be moving around
pretty
fine
now look at the danger of emotions be
careful especially young people what
you're writing your tweets are being
monitored your posts are being monitored
what you're saying and doing is being
monitored as I said we don't if it's h
We Don't Fear the blame of the blamers
but if you just speak upon emotions and
ignorance you may say something is going
to harm you and you can't remove
it and we're talking about when it's in
opposition to what we find in the Quran
and the Sunnah that's what we're
referring to if it's
alhamdulillah look in Islam we are
commanded to Anchor our emotions in b we
have the chapter in the
book The Book of judgments the
chapter should the judge give a verdict
or a ruling and he's upset while he's
angry look at Islam beautiful there
comes in the Hadith abak he wrote to his
son and he was
in don't give a judgment he's advising
his son don't give a judgment between
the people while you are angry he
said indeed I heard the messenger of
Allah s wasallam
say no person who is a judge between two
people should give a verdict and while
they are angry while you're angry you
don't give verdicts while you're angry
you don't speak you take a moment you
calm
down you speak when you have your senses
when alhamdulillah you're calm and
you're
Collective hastiness is from the devil
just rushing out there to say something
you may say something it might harm you
in the and the take your
time young people take your time again
not because we fear the blame of the
blamers no because if you say something
that opposes and it's going to harm you
at this
stage somebody is asking what can I do
living in the west cuz I can't just sit
back and
watch so it's a good question what can
can I do because I can't just sit back
and watch my these my brothers and
sisters even if they weren't Muslims W
it would it would grie any human being
even n watching non Muslims being killed
like this W should upset a
personl answered this question in his
book
of when he talks about politics in the
Islamic
sense he answered this question
in when he talks about politics he has a
book about politics and governance in
the Islamic
sense when he spoke about those who are
unable to establish justice through the
instruments of rulership and legitimate
struggle look what he
said
he said those who implement the on the
person who implements what they are able
from sincere advice with their
hearts supplicating for the well-being
of the umah and loving good and its
people and they Implement what they are
able to do they will not be brought to
account for what they're incapable of
this is for the person they don't have
any rulership they're not a Muslim ruler
and there's no legitimate struggle
there's no legitimate Jihad because
you're not in a Muslim country
and there's no such thing as
vigilantism in order for offensive Jihad
you need a Muslim ruler go back to the
books of the S defensive is in Muslim
countries so he said the one who is
unable to establish the religion through
rulership meaning you're not a ruler or
there's no legitimate struggle that is
taking place but they do what they are
able to do from
what they have sincere advice with their
hearts meaning they grieve what they say
Grieves them
they make Dua they supplicate for the um
they love good and they do what they
what they are able of good they will not
be brought to account for what they
incapable of that's a general
principle Allah will not bring a soul to
account for more than it can bear you're
accountable for what you're able to do
there is no obligation if you're
incapable of doing something if you
can't pray standing up then you sit down
even if you were in a situation
where you it was time to pray and you
didn't have any clothing there was
nothing around you were still have to
pray because you don't have a choice the
religion is beautiful so what can we do
number one supplicate to Allah for the
well-being of the people of paradise Dua
is the weapon of the
believer Dua supplicating to
Allah waking up in the last part of the
night look the
prophet look what we find
in
said the prophet woke up one night and
he says
Subhan what has being shown to me from
the trials and the tribulations this
night he
said who's going to wake up the women
who are sleeping in their stations
meaning his wives who's going to wake
them up for what to pray who's going to
wake them up so when FNA comes how many
people how many people are waking up and
praying in the last third of the night
look at the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when F came he said who's going
to wake up who's going to wake up the
women in their dwelling quarters so that
they can
pray he
said it's possible that a woman is
clothed in this world but naked in the
Hereafter may Allah protect us all from
that praying in the last third of the
night giving charity Islam said what you
are able giving charity for food of food
medicine and clothing through trusted
and reliable sources the prophet he
said whoever fulfills the need of their
brother Allah will fulfill their need
all of all of us one day will have a
need whoever fulfills the need of their
brother Allah will fulfill their
need and whoever removes a difficulty
from their brother Allah will remove
from them a difficulty from the
difficulties of the day of
Resurrection likewise what else should
we do what can we do in these countries
we can
make which is the supplication that is
made in the prayer when the Muslims are
going through times of distress like
drought and other than that or they are
being attacked like we see in the sun of
the Prophet sallallah alai
wasam there are various proofs for that
Dua in
in these lands the in the prayers they
can make
du likewise what else can we
do what we are saying should encourage
us all to seek knowledge about the
religion so that when we speak we speak
with
knowledge knowledge precedes speech and
action so when we see what is taking
place you should go and try and learn
your
religion not listening to individuals on
Twitter n or individuals because they
have a following learning your religion
learning Quran attending the mid
learning from the scholars of Islam n
reading their books looking into their
fwa you should these issues have been
dealt with Alani discussed these things
n
previously other than them these issues
obviously is not pertaining to this
specific Naz but similar circumstances
acquaint yourself with their advice what
was what is the advice of the scholars
in these
times learning
knowledge because if you don't have
knowledge how are you going to protect
yourself with the doubts that are out
there the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he said the thing I fear for
you the most is
what misguided imams people that would
utilize the religion to call to their
Innovation and misguidance may Allah
protect us from
that likewise what else can we do
alhamdulillah look if Allah bless you
with knowledge and you can speak or you
can write yes respond write in the
newspapers why not if you're invited
alhamdulillah on a platform
alhamdulillah and you can clarify the H
islamically but Allah blessed you with
knowledge that's firstly and you know
how to express yourself with wisdom why
not speak with
Justice not with just emotions because
sometimes they want to trap you to make
a statement that they can demonize
everyone by it like for example what
happened what was the country
dagistan when the plane landed in
dagistan you had some Muslims imbeciles
on Twitter saying yes this should be the
response to all Israelis in all places
of the world no we don't say that
civilians are safe from us we don't
transgress against innocent civilians we
do not transgress against civilians
otherwise what's the difference between
us and
the that's
nonsense our response is in light of the
Quran and the
Sunnah that's a very important point to
remember that is why you you've lost now
the mor High Ground because you are
condoning transgression against
civilians what's the
F you see some Muslims Mal praising
Hitler are you insane Hitler believed in
the Supreme Arian
race Tyrant a
maniac obviously what I'm assuming and
Allah knows best that individual has
never read Hitler's book or knows
anything about
Hitler we don't praise maniac like
that now likewise how we show the beauty
of Islam and Injustice even with those
who press us Among
Us Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was just even to people that wronged him
people Subhan Allah were responsible for
killing his uncle the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam dealt with them with
Justice when the conquest of mecah when
the upper hand the prophet Prophet wasam
at the upper hand look at the justice
that he gave when he entered Mecca
that's our example when people see you
respond like that it shows one
alhamdulillah that Islam has is Humanity
that's Humanity
Islam human qualities Islam improves
them and makes them better the best
example Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam times of Peace even
times of
War I want to close with this the issue
of boycotting there's a lot of debate
about it and in reality alhamdulillah
it's a matter again it's not something
that the scholars only have spoken about
recently this issue has being addressed
by the IM the IMs of
Islam from the time of the companions up
until
today all we have to do is go
toari the sad thing about it if you
disagree with someone now in this time
and you don't agree with their position
they call you a Jew they call you a
Zionist they call you an agent why
because you chose to drink a a cup of
coffee from a certain
place Subhan Allah
you drink a cup of coffee and this is
the ex extreme position that some people
take so the first thing we should ask
ourselves what is the Islamic ruling of
buying from non-muslims and selling to
them because the premise has to be what
right what does Allah say about this
what does the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam say about it that's the premise
let's start with
that the Islamic ruling of buying and
selling dealing with non-muslims even at
times of war is that it is permissible
to the majority of the scholars with the
condition that it is not Weaponry or
anything that's going to be used in the
war against the Muslims bukari mentions
in his in his Authentic Collection a
chapter again studying if we read bukari
we would know this
issue we would understand this issue
correctly if we were to study what is
the problem problem what is the problem
some of us are not studying
b as the
chapter trading transactions in the book
of the
chapter buying and selling with the
polytheists non Muslims people of shik
and those individuals whom the Muslims
are wor with what's the ruling of
this he mentions the Hadith and ABD
said he said we were with the messenger
of Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
a polytheus came with long
matted he came driving
sheep he was
with wasallam the prophet said to him
he said are these for sale or are they
gifts the polytheist
said these are to
sell the prophet sallu Al wasallam he
bought a sheep from this this polytheus
bukari mentioned this in the chapter to
show that it is permissible to buy from
non-muslims even if there is a war
between the Muslims and that their state
that is the base rule Bali said
explaining this he said trade with
non-muslims it is permissible with the
exception of anything that the enemies
they use against the
Muslims he said the Muslims have
unanimously agreed on the permissibility
of trade with non-muslims from the
people of Dima those who live the
non-muslims who live in the Muslim
State and other than them from the
non-muslims even the people of
har however it is not allowed for the
Muslims to sell weapons and weap
Weaponry to the enemies that they can
utilize so is that clear that's clear
right it is permissible the origin it is
permissible to buy and sell with the
non-muslims even at times of war that is
the base rule that's in
bukari that is according to albari and
the scholars of Islam the Hadith is
clear therefore the issue of boy
boycotting products of certain countries
and companies revolves around around
what it
is weighing the benefits and the
harms I mean the same thing at the time
of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam the money of the ofr they were
using it to fight against the
prophet same thing but listen inshallah
we're going to get there so the ruling
the base rule is that it's permissible
to buy and sell from the non-muslims
even with the people of har meaning the
enemy state or those who live in the
enemy state with the condition it is not
Weaponry or anything that can be
utilized in war against the Muslims
that and many others we ago un quoting
that's sufficient theth Inari go back
you don't have to take my word go back
to bukari the chapter heading the of
bhari is in the chapter headings so
therefore as we said the issue of
boycotting products from certain
countries and companies it is meaning it
is the issue of the benefits and the
harms because the origin of the ruling
is what is
halal in Muslim
countries many senior Scholars
have stated that it is not allowed for
anyone to call for a public boycott
without the permission of the leader
this is the position ofas the permanent
committee fan and other than them I'll
read the the fatwa of the permanent
committee they were asked about this
boycotting American products like
McDonald's and Pizza
Hut the permanent Committee of the
scholars of they said listen to the
response they
said
this is the permanent committee they
said it is permissible to buy lawful
products regardless of their origin as
long as the ruler has not commanded with
the boycotting of certain commodities
for the benefit of Islam and the Muslims
this is because the basis of buying and
selling is permissibility as Allah said
in the
Quran Allah has permitted trade and the
prophet Sall alaihi wasallam he bought
from the the
Jews was asked about boycotting American
companies he
said buy what Allah May La for for you
leave what is
forbidden however the issue come
comes say for example now as an
individual obviously us living in the
west we there's no muslim rulers as an
individual now can you
boycot he mentions that yes his position
was that it is a form of struggle to
boycott certain companies however that's
an individual Choice it is not allowed
for you now to make ilam that you compel
other people or you question their Iman
because they disagree with you because
they may be acting upon the origin in
this issue the base rule is that clear
to everyone they don't see the benefit
like you see it because there's a
difference of opinion as it relates to
what is beneficial and what is harmful
you can't accuse that person of being a
Zionist because he disagrees with you in
your understanding if you want to
boycott you can boycott as an individual
you can boycott what you want you don't
have to drink here you don't have to eat
there that's allowed for you but if
someone someone disagrees with you
because they take the premise the base
Rule and for example they arrive at
another conclusion you can't now
question that person's Islam or the
IM or accuse them of being an agent
other than
that is that clear to
everyone what about encouraging without
making I mean encouraging as well that
needs understanding
who that is for people of knowledge not
people of
emotions I'm going to go to another
stage look what they're saying now and
again like I said if somebody chooses to
boycott alhamdulillah that's up to you
if you want a boycott
alhamdulillah be again the other the
other side is true if somebody is an
individual personal choice I don't want
to I'm going to boycott again we can't
question them either if they're doing it
on a personal level and not making ilam
not compelling others and not making a
public call for it the brother asks n
what about if we encourage others what
level does it stop you have individuals
now they're calling to boycott Saudi
Arabia and the UAE some people are
saying on on on on Twitter they're
saying we should boycott Haj and where
does it
stop where does it stop
look like I said if somebody chooses to
boycott but somebody may say and go a
further level if we're going to the
boycott somebody may say well okay
boycotting you see it's beneficial you
encourage people to boycott what about
hij we pay taxes our tax our taxes are
used to support what's going
on so you're not going to pay taxes
you're going to is hij now what about
hij where do we
stop where do we stop that is why we
speak with
knowledge and alhamdulillah we're not
going don't allow yourself to be
intimidated the te is they're popping
out of the woodwork I put a tweet up the
other day I said you know again I said
those who say that all of the
Palestinians are guilty in Gaza because
they elected Hamas I said they're the
same as Isis because Isis the same thing
I mentioned today in the lecture because
Isis say you know you know civilian
targets from the West they are
legitimate targets because they voted
for those governments the takir is they
came out the woodwork no this is not we
can kill children again we can't allow
ourselves to be intimidated w we fear
that these people they're going to
create havoc in trying to misguide the
Muslims and pray upon their emotions the
people of the Sunnah must be courageous
and we must speak up and we speak the
truth we don't care about those takies
we're not intimidated by them they can
call us whatever they want J agent give
them a dictionary of terms the H is the
H they said the same thing about the
scholars this is not something new when
albani spoke and he gave advice to the
Palestinians they accused him of being
an agent they lied upon him when sheas
spoke about the solution for Palestine
they accused him of being an agent this
is not new when advised as it related to
the first Gulf War they said he was an
agent a mid in after the she gave the
advice they stood up they said he's a
coward after the she gave the lecture in
the Masjid this is not new they're going
to say it why because you oppose their
desires if the the head of the said to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
when he was dividing The Spoils of War
the head of the said to the prophet be
just you're not being just the way
you're giving out the wealth you think
you're going to be innocent they're not
going to accuse your honor your dignity
or your integrity and the head of the
they accuse the the the the Justice of
the Prophet Alat wasam the prophet said
who's just if I'm not just and I'm
trusted by Allah for Revelation for
something greater than this is only D
I'm trusted it relates to
Revelation so the they're going to
attack they're going to try and
intimidate but the people of sun we must
remain firm and alhamdulillah we don't
want to see podcast for hours about Abad
come on man get a
life like don't don't send that nonsense
to me please I don't care who it is you
don't see what's taking place in the
dun look at the heads of misguidance you
can choose one and the mash that you say
that you refer to I'm sure if you were
to ask them about that they wouldn't
agree with with it I'm positive and
Allah knows
best the ones that you try and Surround
yourselves with and again alh we respect
the
now said people are exposed at times of
F this is going to come out who if you
learned and you studied Allah's going to
test us because there's going to be
waves I told some of the brothers man
you better
get the dust off you know and get on
your your bookshelf and take the dust
off the books and crack them open
because it's going to be like it was
before you know now alhamdulillah now
knowledge you know being firm being
patient alhamdulillah it's required
especially of the teachers because
there's going to be a lot of doubts
especially for young people
alhamdulillah I hope that's clear anyone
have a question or anything inshallah
tal maybe one is that clear to the
brother you asked about
n and also be careful advice to myself
and the brothers and the sisters when we
answer these questions be careful the
way we answer them yes State the H but
with wisdom because wisdom is
what you say the right thing at the
right time in the right way because your
point may be correct but the way you
deliver it is wrong and the people
they're waiting to get a clip to
demonize the so they'll say look look
what they're saying look what they done
to Sham look what they done to him shami
just said there is sh in certain places
they I saw videos people send them to me
look what he's saying you defend this
he's saying the people of paradise I
listen to it I said he never said that
we have to be
just we have to be just but at the same
time I advise myself and the brothers
and the sisters be very precise in the
way that you express
yourselves speak but with wisdom know
the audience and alhamdulillah and know
the best way to convey what you are
trying to say if you
cannot whoever is silent will be safe we
find that in the
Sunnah whoever believes in Allah on the
last day speak good or remain silent you
don't know just say I don't know that
shows the Excellence of a man when you
say I don't know it shows that you have
that you have intelligence and you have
you have dignity because all of us there
are certain things we don't know you ask
me questions I don't know there's
certain things I'm not a lawyer I don't
know about law I don't know not like you
know all of a sudden now you have people
on Tik Tok he's a economist a doctor a
pharmacist a scholar all at once he's
everything and maybe he's you know n
he's half empty in all of those areas
but you say if you don't know I don't
know but Allah tells you where to
go ask the people of knowledge if you
don't know ask the schols if you don't
know something I don't know also if
you're uncertain I don't know remain
silent even said no one is being
destroyed because they were silent the
people that are destroyed are those who
rush to speak when you speak you can't
take it back it's left your mouth so you
better be willing to stand by
it so therefore think about what you're
saying before you say it don't rush to
type don't rush to make a video don't
rush to put something on the Internet
just
wait
wait is from the devil taking your time
is from
Allah is there's a saying in
Arabic the one who is Hasty is going to
often fall into mistakes the one who
takes his time inshallah he will achieve
his goal many times take your
time which one this one this don't look
like a question it looks like a Subhan
Allah question this looks like a
book
we didn't pray we're going to pray now
inshallah yeah what's the question about
it Al is clear n defending a person
defending themsel and their land
alhamdulillah is clear is it's not a
problem with that even Islamic
islamically and even according to
international law you can it's allowed
so there's no isal in that the problem
is we don't agree with Islam is not
talking about targeting women and
children how the
inkari the prophet Sall alaihi wasallam
prohibited the killing of women and
children at times of War you accept
theith right okay alhamdulillah so
there's a difference between us
defending ourselves if somebody
like Muslim we can prot first no doubt
the Muslim
nations listen the thing about itd I've
read this cam it's old like I said it's
not this is not jid what you're highight
highlighting but my question to you no
doubt the cam what you're saying is
obvious but again who does it go to to
call for an offensive it goes to you or
it goes to the
ruler it goes to the ruler
so like said go back to he was a
mountain had these discussions with the
various movements they came to him from
Hamas they came to him from the Algeria
they came to him from all over the world
from Chia and they tried to convince the
Sheik was a mountain he said to the
people he
said he said now and this is just a
this is another lecture in itself he
said where in a time do we all agree the
Muslims are weak they said yes the
Muslims are weak he said somebody in the
Muslim lands he said the government
they're not going to let me go and
travel to for example fight in this
place or that place he said so you're
asking me to do something I don't have
the ability to do right now he said also
weapons he said we don't even have our
own weapons we have to take them and buy
them from other companies from
non-muslim countries he said so why are
you focusing so much as it relates to
the Muslims on something that maybe many
of them are unable to do and things that
they is out of their control he said but
what about what are we able to do he
said look what about the AY when Allah
says if you Aid the cause of Allah Allah
will Aid you and he will make your feet
firm he said why do you guys skip over
that and you go to things that people
may find difficult or
impossible go to I'm telling you even
just preparing for today's lecture I was
reading his words and it was like Subhan
Allah these are the IM the IMs and even
when it comes tolam yes his is is
without a shadow of a doubt in the
correct context but we have to be
careful Isis
quote ISIS quote Muhammad Abdul wahab
who understands these words best the
scholars of Islam anyone if they go to
the Quran and they bring a verse from
the Quran for
example fight them wherever fight them
wherever you find them and they Twisted
from his context firstly that's relating
to who that was addressing the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam it was
addressing the believer belies they had
a state it was a time Allah allowed them
to
fight somebody goes to the Quran and
they twist that like the to kill the sah
for
example the thing is who's understanding
these fwa yes
Al but to me the context is clear but if
you have any doubt you say well how did
the scholars of Islam understand these F
aldah they're not going to hide them you
have the likes of fan he has a summary
from many works of Islam im's gone
through I don't know how many works of
and bringing benefits and principles
from the religion from their books
because that's how familiar they were
alhamdulillah these things have a
context and the context is clear yes the
general ruling if the Muslim lands are
attacked the Muslims can defend
themselves even as I said even according
to international law people can defend
their countries however when it comes to
offensive that you're going on the
offensive it requires what a Muslim
ruler it requires a state it requires an
an army it requires order not F
otherwise if you come with these fwa and
you remove the context you're just
calling people to rec to join Isis and
Allah protect the Muslims from that and
Isis they are responsible for a lot of
the damage that we see taking place what
took place after 911 they opened the
gates to the enemies of Islam and they
said here here are the Muslim lands for
you that's why
ABD he said if people spent millions and
millions to ruin the image of Islam they
would not be able to do like the have
done from and other than them may Allah
protect us from that these groups they
will pop up every once in a while and
they will as said the people of
innovation they will not Aid Islam nor
will they destroy Innovation or
disbelief they're just going to weaken
the Muslims further the way that we find
out is Quran Sunnah understanding of the
sahab returning to our Scholars and
asking them for
what's the what's the ruling of having
peace treaty with peace
treaty spoke about peace treaties
without peace the origin of a peace
treaty firstly peace treaties between
Muslims and non-muslims again this is
for one the Muslim rulers and the
scholars of
Islam has a discussion about this
showing the permissibility of of
countries in states of weakness to have
treaties with non-muslim countries the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam had
the
people are going to argue the
circumstances are
different Scholars have spoken about
this that's what I'm saying what should
we be doing again as teachers translate
these for for the people to refer
to translate them make them accessible
for the people so we can understand them
in the right
context and the scholars all of them
don't let anyone fool
you the ABD the M of Saudi Arabia now I
read that he gave 200,000 R to the
people of Gaza people that calling how
much have they given 200,000 R to the
people of Gaza Abbas was known for his
generosity supporting Islamic causes all
around the
world when these Scholars speak it's
because they speak of Love of the
Muslims and they understand the harms
and the benefits is not based upon
emotions how long have the people been
demonstrating we've been Dem how long
have they been demonstrating for the
poor people of Palestine how many years
how many
decades may Allah protect the Muslims in
Palestine
remove their difficulty may Allah give
them Victory may Allah forgive them and
pardon them and we ask Allah to Pardon
us as
well